How do we actually achieve the principal of access control?
How do we achieve accountability?
Well, we have to first uniquely identify someone.
If you haven't uniquely identified.
The principal of access control.
You may recall when we talked about the access control services, identification, authentication,
authorization, and accountability, the other name that we gave for accountability.
This most important thing that we do in access control is the principal of access control.
Accountability is the principal of access control.
The principal of access control is accountability.
How do we actually achieve the principal of access control?
How do we achieve accountability?
Well, we have to first uniquely identify someone.
If you haven't uniquely identified something, can you make them accountable for their actions on a system?
Next step is we have to properly authenticate someone, verify their identity.
Make sure they are who we think they are.
We then have to properly authorize them.
Using concepts at least privilege and need to know separation of duties,
we need to give them appropriate access on the system.
And then we need to log and monitor what they're doing.
And only then can we achieve the principal of access control accountability.